first thing that resonates is that it
seems to me that the question of
comparing the grants and media with in
terms of integration is complicated
these days impressed for example if we
were to mention the number of people who
were expelled from the US on a yearly
basis I think it would justify many
French before making that after all
we're not doing that bad that's one of
the reasons why it in spite of my own
interest in english and in french
american comparisons i systematically
avoided making this transatlantic
comparison of congrats in the u.s.
because i think would defeat the purpose
for pointing out how dreadful the
situation has been however I think it is
an issue comparison
suggestions for that direction my
argument is few minutes will be released
on the link which i think is difference
in France and in the u.s. between race
and integration which I think it's a
different combination and I want to
present that to aspirants the first hand
has to do with the so-called problem of
immigration as you may know in France
the discussion of education have been
focused on this obvious fact that there
is a problem of integration the compares
to the u.s. is actually what issues
because you think of the number of
illegal immigrants and friends exactly
is somewhere between 300,000 and 400,000
for a population of 65 now if you
compare that to us or you see that in
fact if we're talking about an objective
probably one of that means that is in
terms of numbers we're clearly not in
the same week that is
no se 11 No
less concentrated in specific space oh
then clearly the question are we talking
about big problem or small problem
there is a problem oh but we're not
talking about the same weight of this
issue now on the one hand then
objectively in terms of numbers
integration or a taste illegal
immigration shouldn't be such a problem
transparent anyways however in political
discourse it has been much more of a
problem impressed than it has been in
West I'm not saying that there's no
discussion of immigration who has a
quite aware of the fact that it's also
real issue but I think it would be safe
to argue that impressed the last 30
years have been defined by the so-called
problem of immigration in public
discourse so on the one hand objectively
in terms of numbers immigration is a
bigger issue in the US but in political
terms it's a bigger problem in price now
if we take that seriously that helps
understand how it's worked and Prince if
you listen to politicians when they say
is there's a problem
and our job is to resolve that problem
but if you think it's not just an issue
but it's a political problem then you in
turn things around the job partition has
now been to resolve a problem it has
been to fuel a problem to make it last
not to make it go away and this you can
see the current political campaign you
can see that basically whatever
suggestions made that we should do this
for that well someone has to up the ante
someone has a little further so for
example if poss wrote it on the
socialist candidate start saying we
should do a case-by-case resolution of
the immigration problem was used to the
discourse of the right and Socrates
Socrates says that's the problem given
case by case that means you're going to
legalize everyone or if all you have is
he says conference where he said before
I oppose the boat of foreigners in local
elections then mountain would bet the
extreme right candidate ups the ante and
says the problem is not alone it's that
you're naturalizes
corners so the logic of this is not to
resolve the problem but to continues to
make it bigger and in one of the 11 ways
in which was made bigger finally put us
up as he was when he changed the problem
that is the formulation of the problem
in 2005 by introducing the opposition
between us will she meet us a choice in
question chosen or not now that's
interesting is that this change of
language made it possible to leave out
the question of whether we're talking
about illegal immigration and made it
possible to start addressing legal
immigration as a problem because it was
not chosen because it was family of
immigration for reunification turned by
national marriages so it was not chosen
but instead therefore it was fighting
problem so the shift of language was
meant to make what could be a small
problem a few hundred thousand
the payments into big problem that's all
kinds of foreigners all kinds or legal
or not now one aspect of this is that of
course it makes it more more into a
racial problem that is it's not just an
immigration immigration has become sort
of code word for talking about grace and
prayers if we were just talking about
the 400,000 illegal immigrants well that
I'm a fact where they're talking about
immigrants as you know in France we're
talking also have the descendants
fragrance we're not just talking about
foreigners we're talking about French
citizens and this is the second point
that I want to pick
now if we have a problem in the creation
we can imagine that there will be a
sharp division between the right and
left this issue as you know that hasn't
quite been the case and you watch
further debates but you may have burst
into tears as you heard that's what I
don't conceding so much ground now what
is interesting is on the one hand we
know why the right has been developing
this discourse about immigration as a
problem and at the same time by Islam as
a problem conflating the two or the
logic of national identity that has been
defended by the right first mate rewrite
that by the right and now our division
between the two is quite unclear to me
so this evolution of the right makes
sense in fact they're talking about race
they are talking about national identity
but we know that national identity means
others and all the term immigration and
national identity that defined the
mystery that was created by us a cuisine
2007 50 made it very easy to understand
that was us versus them and there was a
racialization of them then of course we
meet all kinds of people oh and us only
meant us white people implicitly and
we're more explicitly now this
racialization of the so called
immigration issue is not specific to the
right I think the reason why we can
worry about what's going on price today
and this I think introduces a difference
with the American situation is that
accommodation would race place
differently and in particular now we can
look at
French situation you see that so the
socialist happening has not dared oppose
immigration policies as they have been
developed basically it's done the same
thing that we heard it's giving my I do
five years ago which is basically to say
I will do the same thing but in more
humane fashion why doesn't the let or at
least the socialist-led clearly break
away from this white blanke discourse
about immigration one greater makin book
Zinfandel
from the top is that it has to do with a
representation of the working class or
of the people let and France has been
traumatized by the fact that many
working-class voters have deserted the
left and some have chosen the National
Front others in 2007 apparently your
furnace opposite now the idea is that if
we want to win back these voters we need
to talk about national identity and in
fact we need to download whiteness that
mining has in the center of the
political districts that has been
developed on the left the only way many
people to left think and it might be
won't worry to win back the popular vote
that is the working class vote is to
emphasize whiteness and so in many ways
what is happening is comparable to an
issue that I think me was bored
with all these whiteness was developed
good works on whiteness have been in
part developed in the context of the
1980s that is of the Reagan Democrats
the these working-class voters chose to
side with the Republicans for racial
reasons now that is why did you see
because in fact I think the difference
between the French context today and the
politics of lightness and the mountains
of whiteness in the 1980s us and says is
that any was it was not so much about
English the politics of lightness that
develop that that work about
african-americans not what it was
the second difference no of include
without the second difference between
the French and the American situations
on this issue is that if we compare what
happened in terms of grace I think there
has developed in France and throughout
your new theme which I mean of defines
Europe in many ways today in a way that
hasn't defined the u.s. I think
lightness is not just about lightness
it's about sexual whiteness that is it's
not just about the working class it's
about a difference between us and them
and what is the difference between us
and them well if you're a racist you say
it's because they're different but if
your modern and democratic you say it's
because they don't treat their women
well that means that you're not in any
way renouncing democracy on the contrary
you're defending sexual democracy the
rights of women why not Reza case and
the reason why you're defending us is
because you want to preserve Democratic
animals this theme would you find in the
Netherlands for example or but
throughout Europe I think it's one of
the keys to understanding the new
meaning the whiteness in Europe which i
think is readily different from what has
and captured in the US by generations as
well stay